Anders the question that I have and I
think Tom would agree is can they come
up with a solution for Syria even if
they agree or is the country to broken
right now to really fix I don't see
Putin and Obama agreeing on Syria Obama
is strongly against the continuation of
the Assad regime and Putin is all about
maintaining Assad in power because the
sod is protecting Putin's base naval
base at TARDIS and that's a very
important base to him Syria has been
Russia's main allies since 1972 and
Putin really wants to maintain Assad in
that power position and the people who
are fighting Assad the various different
groups have said they won't negotiate
with Assad so unless Putin is willing to
cast him under the bus there's no hope
yeah Assad has killed 250 300 thousand
people in Syria he has gassed his people
he's dropping barrel bombs on them the
rebels the Sunni rebels there will not
negotiate I just saw Lawrence of Arabia
for the first time in ages and there's a
scene at the end where Anthony Quinn
standing up on the table or whatever in
Damascus as the Arab League tries to get
its act together the borders from TE
Lawrence they're gone aren't they the
borders of Iraq the borders of seir see
Syria are gone turkey is a little
concerned about this to say the least
Anders court where are we five years
from now with our new borders are there
any well Syria and Iraq are both very
clean series definitely a failed state
at this point Iraq is close to it those
borders don't matter that Mike and I
memorized in school those borders are
not there anymore people are moving back
and forth they're totally even the
border between Turkey and these areas is
insecure people are flowing over them
foreign terrorist fighters are coming in
from all over the world 25,000 foreign
terrorist fighters have gone into Syria
and Iraq what is the implication of a
failed syrian state for the world well
it's chaos it's dangerous there's a lot
of attention to it there's a lot of
refugees so the refugee crisis that's
flowing into Europe is a serious issue
for the stability future stability of
Europe is this Afghanistan post Russia
on steroids where it becomes the home of
the world's terrorist groups and we get
the refugee crisis on top of that yes
and I don't think that Putin right now
has the military or economic muscle to
really go in and do counterinsurgency
operations but he's got a problem
because they've got 20 million Muslims
in that country and there are much
softer target than the United States
which has been hardening against
terrorist attacks for a long time right
and I think that it would be a major
mistake for Putin to align himself to
close look Assad regime but you were
expert at we go to the Mediterranean and
a lot of people like me don't understand
Syria has shoreline on the Mediterranean
that's where the Russians are how
effective can those troops be and that
military material be inland how far
inland do you envision that mr. Putin's
people can work well the Jets and the
ala copters attack helicopters he's
putting in there can cover most of the
country in Syria how hundreds of miles
and yes however they're not going to be
very effective they can do pinpoint
strikes against a terrorist here there
but they're not going to be very
effective in doing anything other than
defending tardis Latakia and the Assad
regime he can defend what he's got now
he can't really make many gains well we
have seen now the world start to employ
air strikes within Syria against Isis is
there some way the US and Russia are
going to be able to work together
against that one faction well I mean
week again we can do pinpoint strikes
without boots on the ground we're not
going to do much even with boots on the
ground we weren't effective in Iraq and
Afghanistan so that's not a very viable
strategy Petraeus has promoted safe
havens for refugees he's promoted
potentially no flight sounds however
even if you do have a safe haven for
Refugees in Iraq or Syria that could be
a location where jihadis could rise as a
base how does I want to make you work
this morning you've been a critic of the
president administration in their
foreign policy what are they getting
right what is
john kerry getting right is he deals
with these intractable issues well I
think that they're trying to support the
current Premier of Iraq and I think that
is the right thing to do right now the
current Premier of Iraq is a Shia
however he's resist he's somewhat
resistant to Iran he's currently been
forced by pressure from Iran to align
with Russia Iran Assad their potential I
you know he's announced that there's
going to now be a communications and
command and control center in Baghdad
which is you know shows that we're
losing influence we need to we need to
reinvest in he's in his Premiership
trying to bring him back to our son
David girl jump in light of that we have
this news that Iraq is now going to be
sharing intelligence information with
folks besides the US how big a deal is
that for us to Brooke that's a big deal
we really need to do more to bring him
back to our side we and it shouldn't be
too too expensive to support that regime
locally in back that I'm not saying that
we're putting ground troops into all of
Iraq I'm just saying we need to locally
support him to resist influence as much
as possible from Iran and Russia I look
on ders it it where we are in the drama
before the United Nations are these
boilerplate speeches or will there be
real messaging well Putin is really
grand standing at the UN is that a
boilerplate speech with yes yes he's
absolutely out there trying to gain
public support by showing that he's
supposedly trying to to put a hand
towards Obama and ask for cooperation
but in fact he's asking for something
that we will never do it I Mike I saw a
photograph of the two leaders I don't
know when it was a months ago the
difference in body language I don't
believe I've ever seen a stark in the
diplomatic photograph well there's not
to your different people yeah they're
completely different personalities and
and levels of experience in negotiation
I'm just wondering enters the news flow
out of the region so bad and so
continuously bad is this just a disaster
in the making a train like we're sitting
here like Gomez Addams waiting for the
two trains to crash a disaster that's
coming down the tracks that nobody's
going to stop it's a very intractable
issue the United States has to be very
very careful not to get too involved
just partially because of the money
we've spent trillions of dollars if you
include interest payments if you include
all of the extra payments that go along
with these wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
we do not want to throw a lot of good
money after bad money there I'm just
course thank you so much greatly
appreciate this morning